the coronavirus continues though to
ravage india with
thousands of people dying there every
single day
american donors have started sending in
aid and now members of the las vegas
community are hoping to do the same
orkomana shares how they're stepping in
to help in a story you'll only see here
on eight news now
well denise the bright lights of the las
vegas strip are thousands of miles away
from
india but help knows no distance we
spoke to people organizing a local
fundraiser
to send life-saving supplies to india to
help
battle its covert 19 crisis my aunt my
dad's youngest
the youngest sister she passed away with
kuwait anu pandey knows the horrible
heartache this pandemic can cause
although she lives in las vegas she's
immensely impacted by the coronavirus
crisis in her home country of india
a devastating covet-19 surge in india is
killing thousands of people
every day and infections are
skyrocketing i can feel the pain i
understand what my family is going
through and it's not my family there are
millions of families they're going
through the same pain that's why pandey
is helping organize the walk for india
through the new non-profit vegas cares
humanity
the fundraiser which includes a
three-mile walk and musical performances
has a simple goal
collecting funds and sending the medical
equipment to india
specifically oxygen concentrators
because of a lack of oxygen at indian
hospitals
since there is no oxygen enough oxygen
some people are sent
home and that's how they are dying vegas
cares humanity founder renuka moore says
they're working with the consulate
general of india in san francisco to get
the supplies to
india we just want to touch people
and save them and pandey urges the
entire las vegas community to show their
support
together i'm very positive we can make a
difference
it's 20 dollars to participate in the
fundraising walk
and the event will happen twice on may
16 and may 22nd we have more details on
our website
8newsnow.com reporting live near the las
vegas strip tonight
orco mana 8 news now